PRESENTER: Hello, and welcome
to addressing racial disparities
in health care.
Thanks to all of our participants
who are joining us today
from all around the world.
This webinar is brought to you by
Harvard Online and the Disparity
Solutions Center at
Massachusetts General Hospital.
We're excited to introduce
you to our moderator
and panelists for today's event.
Our moderator is Aswita
Tan-McGrory, one of the faculty
who teaches our upcoming course,
"Reducing Racial Disparities in Health
Care."
She is also the Director of the
Disparities Solutions Center
and Director of Equity and Care
Implementation at Massachusetts General
Hospital.
Hello, Aswita.
Thank you for joining us.
And now, I'll let you introduce
the rest of our panelists.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Thank you, Jim.
I want to welcome everybody and
thank them for joining us today.
And I have three colleagues,
and also friends, with me today.
I have Dr. Lenny Lopez, Andrea
Madu, and Dr. Esteban Barreto.
And so I'm going to
kick off this webinar.
We're going to have a lively discussion.
And as was previously mentioned,
if you have questions,
please submit them
through the Q&A function,
and we will use the last 15
minutes to go through those.
But first, I want to ask
each of the panelists
to go ahead and introduce
themselves, and then really
kind of let us know what is sort of
the driving force for you in doing
this work around addressing
racial and ethnic disparities
and working on equity.
And Lenny, I'll start with you, and
then Andrea, I'll have you go second.
LENNY LOPEZ: Well, thank you, Aswita.
It's wonderful to be here and on this
panel on this very important topic.
My name is Lenny Lopez, and
I am a Professor of Medicine
and the Chief of Hospital Medicine
at the University of California San
Francisco and the VA
Medical Center here.
And I'm also a health-care disparities
researcher and implementation science
researcher.
I think for me, the disparities work and
illumination of disparities and really
bringing equity to health care
comes from my family experiences,
and also by patient care.
Every day, I see individuals
that are challenged
by access barriers, challenges around
language barriers, lack of access
to high-quality care.
And most importantly, from the moment
that they enter the health care system,
from registration all the
way to their outcomes,
equity has to be the
number-one True North.
So that's really-- my passion
and energy comes from that.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Thank you, Lenny.
Andrea?
ANDREA MADU: Hi, everyone.
My name is Andrea Madu.
So happy to be here and excited to
have a conversation on this topic.
I am currently a consultant
at the Bridgespan Group,
and I work largely with
nonprofits and philanthropists
to accelerate their impact and solve
really tough challenges centered
around equity.
But I started my career in health
care, working to address disparities
for youth regarding HIV/AIDS,
and then working at the DSC
with the panelists on this call.
I'm really interested in
this work, because I've
seen for myself the differential
treatment that people
receive based on language proficiency.
My family emigrated from Nigeria
in the '80s, and I remember going
to the hospital as a child and seeing
how doctors treated my grandmother,
who could not speak English--
very different from me and my siblings.
And also my mom, who speaks English
fluently, but has a strong accent,
would have to use her knowledge as a
nurse to really navigate the health
care system and for her to get respect
and be treated with the respect
that she deserved.
So those experiences
have always fueled me
to work on reducing health
disparities in health care,
and I've seen how this poor treatment
can translate to poor outcomes
for patients.
And then, personally, for myself, I know
there's a very high maternal mortality
rate for Black women
regardless of class.
And I've always been terrified of
the prospection of giving birth,
because I know what the outcomes
are for people who look like me.
And so I'm always terrified
for my family members,
even though they're in
the medical profession.
So in a way, it affects me, it
affects the people in my family,
and that realization has
made me want to advocate
for people who may not have the
privilege and knowledge to navigate
through that health care system.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Thank you, Andrea.
Esteban.
ESTEBAN BARRETO: Thank you, Aswita.
Great to be here.
Thank you so much for the invitation.
Similarly to Lenny and Andrea, a
lot of my passion for this work
comes from lived experience.
As an immigrant to the
US myself, I also had
to navigate different systems with my
family, especially the medical system.
And having family members go through
different language barriers really
allowed me to focus
on this type of work.
I would also say, from
early in college, I
started working as a
research assistant and worked
in a variety of different research
and quality-improvement projects.
And that gave me a great exposure into
inclusive data-collection techniques,
also different sampling
techniques that we
could use that allows us to hear
from those patients who may otherwise
be excluded from routine assessments.
So I will say it's a combination
of both lived experience,
and also early professional
experience, where it really
allowed me to explore barriers
in a more tailored way
and hear from those
voices who may, as I said,
may otherwise be excluded
from different assessments.
Once again, great to be here and
on this important conversation.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Thank you.
I think the overwhelming theme I'm
hearing is, this is personal to us,
right?
Very personal.
I mean, not only do we--
are we motivated because, as many
people say, it's the right thing to do,
but also it resonates with many of us.
It's the people that we love,
that we see as patients.
It's the experiences we
had in our past childhood.
So I think there's a lot
here when we do this work.
And I think it's also a way that we
have to sort of protect ourselves.
I'll just put that out there.
This is tough work.
And having a community of like-minded
colleagues and friends like you guys
goes a long way into creating
that sort of safe space.
A lot has changed in this
field since the pandemic.
And I kind of want to talk
about that, because we were
doing this work before the pandemic--
really launched the center with
the IOM report on equal treatment.
And so we have seen this
arc of how this has changed.
And I would say, the last
three years in particular
has been sort of amazing,
but also challenging.
So I would love to hear from
you, from your perspective,
how has the field changed,
and how we do this work?
And I'll start with Andrea, and
then Esteban, have you go second.
ANDREA MADU: Sure.
So I'll caveat that I was working
in philanthropy during this time,
but I was working with a lot of
organizations that are addressing
the social determinants
of health and are
kind of working in
tandem with hospitals.
I remember before the
pandemic, it was always
an uphill battle to try and convince
people why this work was important.
We had the data, but the data
hadn't come into sharp focus yet.
Once the pandemic hit, and it was
very clear that, one, leaders of color
were on the front lines and were
also having a higher rate of COVID,
and then the service providers as well
were from the same background, all
of a sudden, everyone was
investing in these organizations
led by people of color, who'd been doing
this work since the beginning-- were
taking on an extra burden.
And so it really did
bring into sharp focus
the idea that this pandemic is
something everyone's dealing with,
but it's actually affecting
these specific populations.
So that was, to me, exciting to see,
because finally, the work that we
had been doing was very evident.
But then, kind of a few years
later, and coming back to that work,
because this pandemic
has been declared over,
even though people are
still dealing with this,
I fear that there's kind
of a retracting now,
where that knowledge is kind of going
backwards and less focus is on it.
So I think in my opinion, I
think we've moved forward,
but then there's kind
of a pendulum swing
back, where I think more of that
work needs to continue to be done,
so that people are still educated
on why this is important.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY:
Yeah, I think the burnout
rate is high on a topic
like this, and it can be.
Esteban, what do you think?
ESTEBAN BARRETO: Yeah, and I agree
with the points that Andrea brought.
And also, as you just said, a lot
has changed since the pandemic.
I remember, right before
the pandemic, I was still
working on my doctoral
dissertation, which
focused on the effects of
diversity, work culture,
on different organizational outcomes.
And I remember when I was trying
to argue for the need of having
a diverse work culture.
It wasn't as clear.
I felt there were a lot of pieces
that I was trying to really argue for.
But then, during the pandemic, as there
was an increased sense of urgency,
I feel like if I would have written
that dissertation during the pandemic
or after the pandemic, I
wouldn't have to explain myself
so much, in terms of the importance
of having a diverse workforce,
particularly in health
care settings, where
we serve diverse patient populations.
So yes, I think it creates
a sense of urgency.
A lot of people wanted to know about it.
Leaders focusing not only
their efforts, their resources,
but maybe reconsidering
their values at both
the professional and personal level.
But yet, there's a lot of
work that has to be done.
I also agree with Andrea that
there may be some backtracking.
At the moment, I'm not sure
what that really is about,
but especially during the
first wave of the pandemic,
we did see a lot of energy in
trying to tackle these barriers.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: You know,
you raise an interesting point,
and Lenny, you and I have
talked about this-- this idea
that I think everybody
can now get on board
with the importance of diversifying
our workforce, our team, our providers.
And that seems a comfortable
space, to a certain extent,
for people to talk about,
particularly in health care.
But this idea of, and it has to be
paired with equitable care, or making
sure that there's no racial
and ethnic disparities,
has sort of gotten less traction.
Lenny, can you talk a
little bit about that,
from your perspective
of overseeing hospital
medicine in a clinical
setting, and being chief--
the challenges of that?
LENNY LOPEZ: Yeah, I'm
reflecting on what you're saying,
but also what Andrea and
Esteban were sharing.
Over 20 years ago, the
Institute of Medicine,
now known as the National Academies
of Medicine, Science, and Engineering,
put out a report on equal treatment.
And 20 years ago, the
field was just beginning
the notion of collecting data on
race, ethnicity, and language.
And at that point, we
had to justify that,
and we had to create reams of research
and papers and all of these things,
and policy, white papers, in order
to say this was an important issue.
And I think the acceleration that's
happened in the last few years
has shifted not only the
public discourse, but also
the shift to structural
changes that are needed
within institutions and
between institutions
at both the government level, all the
way down to the health care system.
So the focus has become
less on individuals and more
on how the structures that we have
created as a health care system
perpetuate inequities, and how
can we change those things.
And so there is a level of comfort
that wasn't there even five years ago,
around, well, how do we
actually bring about the equity
that we all feel so important and it has
been front and center since the latest
social justice movements of George Floyd
and others who have suffered so much.
So I think the discussion really,
really has shifted in that direction.
So bringing that equity
back into the forefront,
into the center of the discussion--
that that's really where we're going.
And so data collection is very important
for monitoring and assuring quality,
but at the same time, we
need structural changes
that will allow for true
change over time to occur.
So I think that's really different
and very exciting about the work
that we have in front
of us moving forward.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Yeah,
and it's interesting,
because I think there's a lot
more buy-in, but at the same time,
people are very overwhelmed
with what it would
take-- this idea of structural racism,
I feel, is fairly new to many folks.
And I wonder, Lenny, or
even Andrea and Esteban,
if you feel that sometimes this
idea that it's structural racism
plays a role in it, and
it plays a very big role.
And I don't know that we as a country
have really acknowledged, historically,
how things have been designed.
But do you think that gives certain
people sort of the feeling of a pass?
Like, oh, it's not me, these things
that I can't change or control.
LENNY LOPEZ: Well, I would add that--
very briefly, and I'll let
Andrea respond as well--
is that there is an element
of that, and there's also
that sense of being
overwhelmed and realizing
how deep and large the
problem is, and that it's not
a problem that just
started yesterday, but it's
been several years that have
allowed us to get to where we are.
So when people throw
their hands up in the air,
it could be the past
[INAUDIBLE] we all want
to feel that we're not
causing injury to others.
But it's also the sense of, where
do I begin, and how did this start,
and what happened here.
So I think it's all of
that mixed together.
But I don't-- why don't I give Andrea
an opportunity to share her thoughts
as well.
ANDREA MADU: I agree, Lenny, that
there's a sense of overwhelm.
I think people really resonate
with interpersonal racism.
Like, my additional
actions-- what can I do,
and what have I done that's caused harm?
But when you kind of zoom
out to the systemic lens,
and noticing that it's everywhere,
it's like you're a fish in water,
and it's all over you.
I think it is overwhelming for people.
But on the other side, I found that--
I've seen that a-ha moment
that happens with people
when they start to realize, oh,
this is like historic disinvestment,
and this has happened over
years, and it's all layered.
And I think for some people
who want to do that work,
that education is so important.
They can't-- people can't use overwhelm
as a reason not to do the work.
I've seen the overwhelm
happen, but I've also
seen that transformative, what can
I do, and how can we break down
some of the barriers institutionally.
And I think the course especially
works through that and talks
through the history of racism in the
US, and it kind of lays it in a way
that you really can't deny what's
going on, and just talks more
about tangible ways to address that.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY:
Yeah I feel like that
was a key piece for us to
include in our course was that we
have to acknowledge how we got here.
And it is not something
that is easy to talk about.
But I think Dr. Powell does a wonderful
job of sort us walking us through.
And it can be very eye opening.
A lot of it is stuff that
we did not learn in school.
And I think a lot of
people were surprised
by some of the things he shared.
And so I think that's a key element that
we have sort of built into the course
that we need to start opening up.
Esteban.
ESTEBAN BARRETO: Yeah.
I certainly agree with Lenny and Andrea
in terms of the overwhelming aspect
and also with Andrea's point about
how it shouldn't be an excuse.
Education is where we
should really focus.
Fortunately, we live in--
some of us live in
Massachusetts, where we're still
allowed to teach things
like critical race theory.
In terms of racism, I know there's
a lot of different definitions
and people may have different nuances.
I think of racism as a
system of oppression.
And then, from that, there's a
lot of different types of racism,
and racial discrimination, and all that.
And I think that that is a good
point, a good starting point,
the education of these concepts
and how this phenomena affects
different populations.
But again, I also agree with
the earlier point from Lenny
about the structural challenges.
And we can do a whole lot
in terms of data collection
and trying to learn from
different perspectives.
But then if the structures and,
unfortunately, the politics
get in the way, it just makes
our job much, much harder.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: You know,
it's a good point you make about--
people sometimes ask me,
like, well, how do you
know that equity has been achieved?
And I would say equity
is not the end goal.
Because it is really a journey.
And it consistently has to be monitored.
It has to be deliberate.
We are always learning something
new in this field, I feel.
It's constantly changing.
Terminology changes.
Funding changes.
People's willingness to talk about it.
We've definitely seen a huge change.
I mean, I think a couple years ago,
just mentioning the word racism
in a boardroom.
Like, everybody's shoulders
would be like this.
And so now we're saying it.
Yeah.
You remember?
I mean, you try to do whatever you
can to bring the message along.
So you're like, OK,
let me just soften it.
And I'm happy to see that we can say
the word racism without stuttering,
[LAUGHS] in boardrooms.
I mean, I feel like that's progress.
And so this is really a journey.
I'm curious to hear
from you three, what do
you think we really need in the field?
Like, what is the gap?
There's a lot here, interpersonal
racism, structural racism.
If we think about health care
organizations and health care
in general, what is needed,
from your perspective?
LENNY LOPEZ: One thing I
wanted to add to that--
to answer your question, to add to the
conversation, is that what is needed
IS not only I love
this frame of journey,
also just continued growth
as part of that journey.
I am happy to share that
even after 20 years working
in the field of equity and health care
disparities, I'm constantly learning.
And I'm constantly being pushed.
And I'm constantly needing to
reflect on my own implicit biases,
and my own starting
point, and my own ability
to communicate these things
in the right settings
with the different groups of people.
And I think those are things
that, of course like this,
can really give you that space, no
matter what your level of experience,
or background, or education
around these topics.
it is really, as you're
saying, is a personal journey.
So I think one of the things
that when this course comes
live-- and I'll encourage other folks
to take it-- is, really, to realize
that you don't know everything.
And there's so much space
where you can actually
continue to grow as
an individual and make
those changes in your own place
in the universe where you are,
at work and in the communities.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Yeah.
And I will say, like, we had
long discussions about content
when we started designing this course.
And there's probably
stuff that we weren't
able to include because,
honestly, to include everything,
your course would be a full year.
And then you would still
probably leave things out.
So I think we really
tried to focus on what
we know best from all the
organizations that we've worked with.
What we're the core competencies
that we would want you to know?
What would be some of
the building blocks
that you, as a person, having to think
about transforming your organization
to think about racial and ethnic
disparities, to think about equity?
What are some of the key components
and really bringing in the folks
that we've worked with?
So I totally agree that--
with your point, Lenny.
Andrea and Esteban.
ANDREW MADU: Yeah, I agree too, Lenny.
That humility is so important.
And I think humility was something I
felt throughout this course, the idea
that equity is not something that
we're going to solve in our lifetime.
But there are pieces of it that
we can move along a journey
while we're working on it.
And so I think that was
very helpful to see.
I think, also, just in
general, structurally,
I think what's needed
is a pipeline of doctors
who also looks like the communities
that they're serving and have
that lived experience to understand
the cultural context of what patients
are saying.
That's one.
And then I also think this understanding
of the medical mistrust that
has happened over decades or centuries
and understanding why some people might
not want to come to the
doctor or why people might not
be adhering to treatments.
There are reasons behind that.
And I think really coming to it
with both humility and empathy
to patients I think is so important.
And that kind of goes into
the frame of understanding
the history behind everything.
ESTEBAN BARRETO: Yes.
And I definitely agree with what
was said, definitely a journey.
We have to exercise humility.
Andrea, your comment had
me thinking about how
we move from cultural
competence to cultural humility.
So maybe we have to think
about equity, humility.
And it is not easy to
address health disparities
when there are also
disparities in education,
disparities in the legal system.
And everything kind of has
an effect on each other.
So in order to increase representation
among health professionals,
you also have to address
disparities and equal opportunity
to education, what
children and young adults
are being exposed to, in
terms of future career.
So I think, as in society, there's
a lot that we still need to work on.
We're talking more in particular
about health care disparities.
But I just wanted to make that point
that disparities are really everywhere
in every single system.
So we also have to think about tackling
in other fabrics of our society.
One thing about this course is that,
considering how complex this issue is,
the speakers do explain the topics
in a very comprehensive manner
and provide an examples,
providing different case
scenarios that I was really happy with.
And I found it very
easy to follow along.
And I also have to admit that
I did learn a lot of things,
despite having a few years
working on this field.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Yeah.
Andrea and Esteban were the
early adopters of the course.
They actually went through the course.
And I just want to thank you, first of
all, for taking the time to do that.
But it's very meaningful
to me that somebody
like you gave it a seal of approval and
that you still learned something new.
I think that's an important theme that
Lenny and all of you have brought up
is that when people talk about
subject matter experts, I say,
oh, that's with a caveat.
Because, to be honest, I'm
constantly learning new things.
I'm constantly-- in this work,
you have to self-reflect.
That's really the only area where
you can make some concrete changes.
But you have to reflect on your
own journey, your own reaction
to some of what you work on every day.
And then also, it just changes.
It changes constantly.
It depends who's in leadership
positions, whether it's in this country
or in your institution.
It depends on where the money's going.
So there's a lot of factors.
And so I agree.
I feel like if you're not
learning anything new,
then maybe, I don't know
that you're ready because I
feel like we're constantly learning.
We are sort of early adopters,
probably because [LAUGHS] we've
been doing this work so long.
And I just-- I'm just kind of
curious, from your perspective,
in just giving some--
like, on hindsight,
I wish I had known this
when doing this work.
Like, what are some things that
you would share with the audience?
From whatever role you
feel is most comfortable,
whether it's, like, a physician
leadership role, where it's, Esteban,
as evaluation component
or, Andrea, as, like,
a consultant with a really heavy
vested interest in this topic,
or from a personal perspective.
ESTEBAN BARRETO: So I can talk
about the evaluation work.
One thing that I wish I knew before is
that we love timelines, and deadlines,
and all of that.
In an ideal world, we are
able to meet all the deadlines
for all of our projects.
But then the projects that
have more of an equity lens,
of a health disparities lens, I feel
like you need to be a little bit more
flexible and sometimes pivot.
So when you may plan the perfect
goal, the perfect objective,
you may come up with a perfect
approach to data collection.
And then you may learn that there's
things that you may need to change.
And so I wish that that was one
component that I learned early on.
But now, that is
something that I do stress
when I do meet with
different investigators who
are interested in having an equity
lens to their research portfolio.
And we talk about that flexibility
or that ability to pivot when needed.
ANDREA MADU: I think one
thing I wish I had known
is, one, like, how to identify people
who their minds are just never going
to be changed, no matter what you do.
But I wish I had
learned those strategies
to kind of transform the hearts
and minds around those people.
Because, really, that's how it works
to get those allies on your side.
I think there's one piece of the course
that talks about the Kotter model.
And I think I've always thought
of creating a sense of urgency
was the most important piece.
But there's all of these pieces
of creating the coalition,
but then also try to use
that coalition to get
other people involved and invested.
And that's really what pushes these
initiatives to be successful, more so
than just saying, this
is why this is important.
So I wish I had known that before.
I think now it's really
important in the work
that I do now and especially
in this health care work,
where you are going to have
to change hearts and minds.
And how do you do that
when you might not
be the right messenger for the message?
But you could find that person
to help you along the way.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Yeah.
It was very helpful.
The Kotter model isn't
designed for equity.
But when I read his book, I was
like, oh, my God, this is it.
This is the template of why it's so hard
to change an organization, like, really
all the way through.
And it's-- when you talk about
organizational transformation,
he's identified what
makes it successful.
So I think that's a very helpful
grounding in, sort of, this work, when
you kind of feel like,
oh, I don't know, like,
why is it that I've been
doing this work for five years
but it feels like I've got no traction?
Then I think that model is, from a
business perspective, very helpful.
Lenny?
LENNY LOPEZ: Yeah.
Reflecting on what
everyone is sharing, one
of the things that I've learned over
time in working with organizations,
working within my own organization,
to address the systemic barriers
is that all the sources of disparities
and the solutions for eliminating
those disparities are all
hyperlocal and that you can learn--
The goal is to learn tools and
strategies, for example, the Kotter
model we're talking
about, to really, then,
take it home, and take it to your
institution, to your organization,
to your community, and
your place in the universe.
And that's where the change happens.
And so although we have oftentimes
grandiose ideas about how the world is
going to change and all of
these things, oftentimes, it's
much smaller victories
that add up over time.
And so those are the
things where we're, Aswita,
to use your metaphor,
the journey, those are
the things that give you strength,
and courage, and the energy
to keep doing the work.
And so reframing and organizing your
thinking in that way, essentially
what's available in this course,
is an incredibly helpful process
to go through.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: So my last
question to all three of you is,
this is hard work.
I do feel like once you see
things, you can't unsee them.
And then you see them everywhere.
Like, if you go on vacation,
[LAUGHS] in the grocery store.
And so my question to you is how
do you do self-care in this work?
Like, I love that all four of
us have the lived experience.
It allows me not to have to do the
preamble of why this is important.
I can just skip that and go
straight to how can we do things.
But I really would
love to hear from you,
what is the self-care strategy you use.
And mine, for example, is I don't read,
outside of this job, any heavy books
on racism, social justice.
I don't watch movies about it.
I just-- I've had enough.
i watch really bad trash TV
and read detective novels.
[LAUGHS] But I just know that
I need to refill my tank.
So I would love to hear from the three
of you your strategy for doing that.
Because I think that's an
important piece of all of this work
is the self-care.
So I'll start with
Esteban, and then Andrea,
and then I'll close it out with Lenny.
ESTEBAN BARRETO: Yeah.
For me, some strategies for
self-care is family and friends
having open discussions
about different issues.
I do have to admit that I try my
best to stay current to the news
and everything that is going on.
And I learn how to not take
things personally, over the years.
Also, another big part for
me is working with students.
I'm an instructor at the
School of Social Work Simmons.
And I teach a class each semester.
And working with different
students really allowed
me to also stay current in
different topics, for example,
social issues, the different
nuances, the different ways
that issues are being looked at.
And so those are some of the things
that do help me to stay current,
but also trying to
practice of self-care.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY:
Yeah, there's nothing
like working with young students to get
out, the old, archaic way of thinking.
And it's sort of refreshing.
Andrea?
ANDREA MADU: Yeah.
I feel like I plug in a lot.
Because of my work, I really
have to stay current as well.
I have a group chat
with my family, where
I'm just like, anytime something
crazy happens, I'm just like,
can you believe this?
And we just kind of dish on it.
And it makes me feel like I'm not alone.
I also schedule 30 minutes before
I have a big meeting with someone
that I know is going to be, like,
a struggle, to go on a walk,
or I listen to some
of my favorite music,
just to get me kind of
hyped up to deal with that.
But, yeah, just creating space for joy,
I think it's so important to find joy
wherever you can in this work
because I know it's tough.
But those moments do exist.
And I really enjoy working with people
who are just as passionate about it.
ESTEBAN BARRETO: Yeah.
That's a good point about the chat.
I think we all have folks that we
text to where it's like, oh my God,
this person just said this.
Can you believe it?
And then they'll ping back and,
like, I can't, and I'm really sorry.
And that's really all
sometimes you need.
Lenny?
LENNY LOPEZ: Yeah.
Similarly to all of
the panelists, I'm just
thrilled that we're even having
the conversation about self-care
in this space.
Because I think even 10
years ago, we weren't
talking about self-care and for those of
us doing equity work and justice work,
and realizing that you
have to give yourself
that space in that condition to realize
that the work is larger than yourself.
And so the time that you put into
it, the education, the courses,
the things you do, the
work we do every day,
those are all part of a larger change,
a larger process that you're a part of
and you're adding to.
But it is not all you.
And I think that is really liberating.
But I'm so thrilled that we
talk about self-care these days
because it's so essential
to not be the hero that
dies because of the weight of
inequity and injustice in the world,
so very, very, very important.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Yes.
I mean, if we think about reducing the
stress so that we have better health
outcome, self-care is a big component.
Because the data shows [CHUCKLES]
we're not winning in this spot at all.
ANDREA MADU: Not at all.
[LAUGHTER]
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY:
OK, I think we're going
to turn to some audience questions.
Thank you for that.
I think that's an
important piece that we
didn't sort of talk
about in the course but I
wanted to highlight in the webinar.
So I think there's been
a lot of questions.
And I'm-- OK, first question, can
you outline some of the tangible ways
to address racial inequities
in health care. what tactical,
practical steps can be taken now.
Aside from taking the course--
[LAUGHS] which outline [INAUDIBLE]?
Maybe, let's see, anybody
want to take that question on?
LENNY LOPEZ: Well, it's
a very large question.
And it comes back to my comment
about the sources of disparities,
the solutions of disparities
being hyperlocal.
So, for example, for me, as a clinical
leader at a very large university, what
we've been doing for many years
is starting from the process,
before people engage our health system,
the whole process of registration,
the process of having
access to health care,
and actually structuring it to
prevent the blind spots, that
prevent the processes that
will lead to inequity,
and then building at every level,
from that moment of registration,
to the clinical care, to the
training of the providers,
to the measurement of outcomes, to
the reporting, public reporting,
of those outcomes, on and on at each
step of the way, may sound not sexy.
But that's actually how
change happens and how equity
is established in an institution--
institutional setting.
So that would be the
beginning of a conversation
about the answer to that
question, that this is actually
deep work that requires every level
of the institution to be involved in.
ANDREA MADU: I think I would
add to that, to treat patients
as the subject matter
experts of their lives.
Because there's so much information
that can be gleaned just
by having that rapport with a patient.
And I think in designing solutions,
like Lenny's saying, they're hyperlocal,
I think that also means just having
people within the community that
are trusted to understand where the core
issues are, understand the root causes,
before we kind of go into
the treatment aspect of it.
So I think bringing in the community
in and building that trust as well.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Esteban,
did you have any comment?
ESTEBAN BARRETO: Yeah.
I agree with Lenny and Andrea.
The only thing I will add is
we all know that if you're
trying to find disparities and
you look for them, will find them.
And after you take the course, and
while you're taking the course,
and you're thinking about
a particular project
that you would like to
embark on, I'll suggest
that you get as specific
as you can in your project.
One of the things that
I see for my students,
for example, is that their
goals are very broad.
And we're all trying to solve
everything in the world.
And, unfortunately, we may
not have the bandwidth.
So I will say, at the individual
project level, the more specific
you get, the more tailored, the better--
the most successful you will be to
measure and keep track of the progress.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Yeah, try
not to boil the ocean, I think.
The other piece, sort of
bouncing back to what Lenny said,
is I do think data collection,
that is a tangible step that you
can take as to assess the
quality of your demographic data.
Because out of that comes a lot.
And then, I would say, taking a journey
and looking around in your community
and seeing what are some of
the historical milestones,
things, events that happened that
created the mistrust in the communities
that you serve between the
communities and your organization?
We don't like to do
that, but we have to.
I think that's core to understanding
whether our interventions
or our strategies are going to work.
They won't work if we don't acknowledge
some of the historical events that
have created a lot of the mistrust.
We have to do that hard work.
ANDREA MADU: I just want to quickly
add to what you're saying, Aswita,
and what Andrea was saying, is that,
in this course and in this work,
you have to realize that you're
creating partnerships and ally shifts.
You're not going into a
community to save a community.
Those approaches act
as if the communities
have no resilience, no empowerment,
no resources, et cetera,
when it's often not the case.
So it's really that connection where
the community, and the systems,
and the institutions work together
that leads to long-lasting change.
Because institutions
are within communities,
whether they want to
think about that or not.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Yeah.
This is a good question.
I get this a lot when
we do presentations for,
like, an international audience, which
is, do you feel like racial disparities
and discrimination is a bigger
problem in the United States
and in health care in particular?
Or do you see similar
issues internationally?
ESTEBAN BARRETO: So I could start by
saying that something to keep in mind
is that the way that we conceptualize
these concepts differ in each country.
Even the concept of
race is very different,
the way that we think about
it here in the US versus it
started in Latin America,
in Europe, et cetera.
So that's something that
I wish to say, to keep
in mind that a lot of these
constructs, a lot of these concepts
are particular to a particular culture,
country, and also, moment in time.
ANDREA MADU: I would also
say, again, would echo
that, that racism is seen differently.
Racism's twin sister is colonialism.
And there's colonialism all over the
world that has affected populations.
I think any community
where you see there's
a gradation in color, the people
who are the darkest skinned
are generally the ones that are
facing the most discrimination.
And you will find
disparities there as well.
So I think just because the
conception is different,
it doesn't mean that those
disparities don't exist.
It's just that I think in the
US, we talk about it more.
And it's, like, we have this history of
slavery as well for hundreds of years.
So I think it's just a difference
of familiarity with the concept.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Yeah.
And I would say my home
country is the Netherlands.
And it's known as a
very tolerant country.
But even if we look
deeper under the hood,
there's immigrant
populations who are not
getting the same treatment as
somebody who is Dutch and born there.
There's also religious oppression
that probably mirrors the same thing.
And then there's tribal as well.
We have tribal differences.
So I would say it's really about what
kind of social justice and oppression
do you need to look at,
rather than thinking
that racial and ethnic
disparities is just a US problem.
That's sort of denying that your
country may also have issues.
Lenny?
LENNY LOPEZ: Yeah.
And I would add to what
everyone is saying.
And I think it's also a false dichotomy.
Because in reality, whoever raises the
discussion point, or socioeconomics
is the social point, or colonialism
history is the point, all of them
become deeply interrelated over time.
So when you try to separate one out,
the other is still embedded in it.
And so I tend to tell people
that whether the terms that
are more primary in our context
are meaningful to people,
realizing that they're actually very
similar and they're very correlated.
So trying to separate
those out often leads you
to confusing conclusions
that are usually not true.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: OK.
One more question and
then we'll close it out.
And, Lenny, maybe I'll punt this to you.
So how can we integrate
training on reducing disparities
in formal medical training?
How can medical students
carry this workout?
Medical students are
the next generation.
And so we have to be really mindful
of being able to focus on them
because that is a wave
of change, as we see it.
So any thoughts on that question?
LENNY LOPEZ: Great question.
I think about this a lot, given that I
have trainees always working with me.
And that is is that
the only way to do it
is that it has to be actually embedded
in the four years of a medical school
curriculum, from the very
beginning, and not only the content,
but the making the space,
formal space, for reflection,
or mentoring, or observation of what
other senior doctors may be doing,
handling these kinds of issues
in the clinical context.
So it actually has to
be part of a culture.
And that is done through the
investment of money and time,
protecting educators
times to actually be
able to teach this material,
as opposed to volunteerism,
really embedding it in.
This is an essential
topic that every year,
we're going to discuss
throughout the course work.
But again, that takes
time, money, and investment
from the leadership of the institution.
So very, very important if we're
going to really change the needle.
But it can't be a niche topic that's
done in a small, 10-hour seminar once
or twice in four years.
That is not going to work.
ASWITA TAN-MCGRORY: Yeah,
multipronged effort, definitely.
I want to thank the three of you
for joining me in this conversation.
I knew that we would
have a good conversation.
I stacked the deck by asking highly
intelligent friends and colleagues
to join me on the panel
who I really like.
That just is very helpful and makes it--
I knew all of you would show up and that
you would bring your authentic self,
and your lived experience, and your
thoughtfulness to this webinar.
So thank you again.
And I'm now going to turn it
over to Jim to close us out.
Great.
Thank you, Aswita.
And thank you, Lenny,
Esteban, and Andrea.
And thanks to all of you
who've joined us today.
We hope you'll continue the
conversation in our new online course,
Reducing Racial
Disparities in Health Care.
So thank you again for participating.
And we appreciate your time today.